et voilà et nos deux candidats deux
candidats à nice pensable au bon
déroulement du jeu bien entendu monsieur
est rare toujours pour la cinquième fois
dans votre jeu on n'en dira pas plus
vous êtes toujours en forme ça va ça va
alors un peu nerveux au début d'un jeu
dans toujours toujours chaque fois sur
les principes comme d'habitude votre
adversaire aujourd'hui tu as très jeunes
candidats qui à 18 ans je crois 17 10
rester jeu qui s'appelle monsieur
promène ses seins en est qui et qui
descendent en anglais je vois l'origine
pratiquement un match international
quel est votre je vous dis pas votre
profession mais qu'est ce que vous
faites je suis un être supérieur a donc
à bon quoi les gens là c'est peut-être
bon je ne sais pas je savais pas les
mathématiques sont loin du calcul mental
bien que ce grain il faut vous
décontracter le plus possible d'essayer
la forte partie faire affaire à forte
partie et je viens je vais vous demander
tout de suite de choisir pile ou face
pile et bien c'est pile monsieur
broomhead c'est à vous de commencer avec
le bol plus haut consonne consacre
voyelles voyelles et consonnes personnes
voyelles voyelles et consonnes consonne
voyelle voyelles et consonnes encore et
qu'on sonne creux
car secondes
top c'est beau mais combien de lettres
cinq lettres s'inquiète damien famille
arabe a ra barbara82 max oui oui tout à
fait cet axe-là y avait pas mieux vaudra
mieux que j'ai vu ça aussi mais
peut-être qu'à mieux ça s'imposait bien
cinq points vous démarrez bien monsieur
grenet j'espère que ça va vous donner
confiance en face à un adversaire aussi
difficile que monsieur est rare nous
repassons twittos compte est bon on te
demande vous commencez à bien connaître
maintenant avec mu